John's Incredible Pizza Company the
sponsors of this segment is a world of
fun for anyone even Rocky
John's Incredible Pizza Company is
celebrating 25 years of food and fun it
is the perfect place to be a kid and if
you're anything like me the perfect
place to be a kid again
thing you see when kids walk in is their
eyes just light up with the with coming
in the Johns from the front you see all
the lights especially at night time it's
all lit up and beautiful and you come in
and you see this uh freshly beautiful
rooms like Kaleidoscope which is you
know experience on its own to tune where
we got a Disney themed room to fusion
with this you know Music Room you would
even have Hall of Fame for the dads
where they can watch their favorite
football game and then you get in the
fun world where it's just lights and fun
and games so John farlett our owner came
up with the spicy peanut butter Pizza
you know when he first started this
place and it's our most famous signature
Pizza when it's on this pizza exactly so
it's peanut butter and some spice Flakes
and our incredible John sauce with
pepperoni and actual peanuts we put on
each slice Moment of Truth now while I
taste this what other pizzas are on
there yeah we have a new cheeseburger
pizza we have the chicken alfredo we got
everything from pepperoni to Hawaiian to
thin crust pizzas
whoa
good huh wow
I love peanut butter I love pizza I just
know I love them together yeah it just
works it just works we got everything
from ice cream cookies uh we got our
brookies and then we got you know we
make our chicken and everything from
dressings to every uh pasta we make
in-house and then you got drinks to go
with it and we have adult drinks kids
drinks Icees ice cream which the kids go
nuts for and I just say thank you to
John
thank you John because this is so good
I'm sure he'll appreciate that all right
well if I'm gonna eat I'm gonna be ready
to play in a minute well here you go
let's go play Let's Do It
[Music]
and of course you have all the classic
arcade games here that everyone loves
but you got some new ones we're standing
on them right now yeah we got twister
here we also got uh Mission Impossible
we got Hot Wheels but it's not just
games that we got here we got rides we
got bowling you could even go golfing
and bumper cars we got everything here
at John's for you we have seven party
rooms that you can rent for an hour and
45 minutes and uh that's for our
birthday parties uh you get game tokens
cake you get a you get a party host that
will make balloon animals play games
with the kids and you'll have a great
time also you can do uh corporate events
here and uh holiday parties John's is a
huge uh supporter of the schools the
community if you're an administrator a
teacher you want to get signed up go to
our website johnspizza.com we have great
fundraiser opportunities there you can
reward your students with free passes
for good grades it's all on the website
we'd love to have you here
thank you John's Incredible Pizza
Company for sponsoring this segment you
can find them at the Boulevard Mall more
information call
702-381-55555 or visit johnspizza.com
[Music]